surprise that's crazy but I wonder plays
the French himself as black so we saw a
French we see just kind of a quiet start
to this game trades right nothing too
major C3 let's defend our Pawn let's
just be calm I feel like Yasser sarawan
is somewhere here just like Whispering
moves yes and this is perfect from a
wonder you were saying as a team captain
James this is the type of position you'd
want for your board one against Magnus
Carlson Dive Right into that one the
last couple moves were fascinating we
saw that Magnus took upon an A2 magnets
up one Pawn B3 give me a second Pawn
Rook B1 your Bishop is pin and Magnus
probably hoping that A5 A4 happens
quickly enough but there's an issue that
when does Knight captures the enemy
Knight on F6 the queen can no longer
take back you have to take with your G
Pawn that means your king is not very
safe the queen will replace the Knight
after the Knight takes the enemy Knight
and there's going to be a vicious attack
against the black king a Wonder laying
by the way up nearly three minutes on
the clock oh yeah that's that's and
there it is he's going 485 is probably
the only way that he could do things
here these French middle games are
actually some of the most tactical you
will ever see for both sides because
white is trying to rip your head off
here and black is counter-attacking left
and right so of course as you see white
is just trying to go for me black on the
other hand I have a pass a pawn here and
I'm up so if I'm able to you know get
out of your stuff or your checks or
whatever you're trying to do I'm gonna
be okay
wow actually good point because this
King might Dart to E7 it could be pretty
safe there you don't really want to take
this Pawn on H6 your king is in the line
of fire so after Queen E4 king f8 or
something like that maybe A4 first but
check King f8 I don't think you take
this Pawn you might just get checkmated
that is crazy white could be in trouble
here this could definitely turn they
love white so we're gonna check and then
what's the follow-up
I don't know
idea check oh check Bishop C4
oh James
showed that real quick A4 check Bishop
C4 your Bishop is pinned because your
Queen's behind it threatening Checkmate
over here maybe the queen has to go back
you can't bring the Rook up that's
Checkmate here yeah I mean probably has
to go but then you can even just take
this and take it yeah and maybe we're
pushing for more and then the H6 is now
hanging right so there's some
possibilities there
nice fine by you the bishop C4 is classy
and necessary and that's why Magnus deep
in the think tank he is now down to a
minute and 35 seconds whereas his
opponent is 449. why this problem check
you just go put forcing you can bring
your queen take this pump with check it
looks like black is the one for Choice
yeah
oh my God
a Wonder Liang is a beast at bug house
he sees tactics like this he plays it
just check the queen is goodness he's
busted he's completely busted here
Magnus about to go down so they're best
in the final match a Wonder Liang has
Bishop B5 check bring them all to the
party and he's gonna beat Magnus Carlson
in this game
though Magnus sort of will be praying
for counter play there but he finds the
check Magnus might just throw in the
towel right now I saw the Charlotte
chess Center uh chatting everyone is
about to lose their Channel points and
you see Magnus he has resigned he's
mentally out of it and he just knows
that this game is over I wonder Liang
the hero for the cobras
who opening choice for Magnus there
inches that are lightest but sometimes
they're very strong work takes CAO my
goodness
still fighting not giving up no you can
you can do is you could take this Rook
like Queen f8 check and queen takes F7
check because the bishop will have to
take and your queen is Left unguarded
Behind it that's beautiful Daniel
nerdinski that is something that the
world struggles with Donna and we see a
wonder he's doing it he calculated this
to the end that's what he was doing he
was making sure this is easy for white
mm-hmm yeah he didn't want to you know
give Magnus any type of chances like
it's Magnus Carlsen don't give him no
chances he takes on F7 finds the move
take date and that's done
so they went to even oh what's happening
oh man bro that's crazy chess is like
this is ridiculous how is this a draw
you gotta be kidding me yeah
he's kicked out no way Madness could win
this game he could it's very possible
Rook B5 he has to go directing Rook beef
oh maybe not okay where's he going with
the Rook that's what I thought oh
he might just run this way back around
but the bishop will lock it in once you
get this Pawn here the bishop comes to
B1 and The Rook is locked on A1 oh it's
locked in there he misses it
okay wait he goes up
he decides to go up here which means The
Rook can stay behind the pawn forever
that's good news for you I wonder and we
can push the f and g is our goal and try
to walk those boys through get the king
active too as well uh Magnus shaking his
head here he doesn't know he's like ah I
probably had to draw right 11 seconds so
it's hard to do that in 11 seconds
but what if Magnus ends up pushing his
pawn and bring his King to B6 you will
kick this Rook away because if it goes
up you go back and if it goes up you go
back we might see a repetition of the
sort there might be right there actually
and then my king is too far away you can
actually walk your king up to try to
take the C3 Pawn while distracting the
rook and by uh pushing the a pawn to to
keep that under control so if we get to
take the C Pawn then the b-pawn gets
rolling in who's winning
and that's the great thing about Bishops
right it protects A4 also covers the
promotion Square so F4 plate Max has to
play B5 if G5 will see a swap and a king
going right to B6 trying to kick this
Rook away Magnus Carlsen might hold this
game I really think that it's uh kind of
the trajectory is more towards a
magnet's draw than a Wonder win he had
right exactly right which has like
Magnus effect the magnet straw what is
going on right Maxie how does he do it
you know chess is too hard Greg exactly
I don't know how Magnus does it it
looked completely lost it was completely
lost and now he was King B7 and if Rook
A5 King then we might see a draw by
repetition jeez
okay
he's going for now this is what oh but
his well this is a race right right this
is yeah
you were saying what if that King just
goes for C3 right and the bishop yeah
he's gonna go back but if these pawns
were connected this would probably be
winning for white I think but here we
can walk the king up take the pawn sack
the bishop for that pawn you gotta walk
the king all the way up oh I can't cross
oh yeah that's a thing Kinks Rook A1 I
can't cross no the king can't cross me
is he trying to go this way now
oh he could be going that way yeah he
could run up that way
um
oh because rookie went up King E4 he's
crossing a bit slower but he's making
sure his King gets in over here in the
water down to seven seconds he might
lose this game get out of here oh hold
on to your hash chat oh my oh my gosh
Here Comes The King
oh it's waiting for black how does
maggas Carlson do this let's take it he
just takes this Pawn the bishop the long
range piece covers G8 protects A2 the
black king sleds in and Magnus Carlson
is winning in this position he's
actually just gonna use the second Pawn
James Canty is nowhere to be seen on a
victory or Magnus a w will appear and
look at one oh man you see it you see it
I mean he probably says adult language
just now
a Wonder Liang could have had four out
of four today but look at Magnus shakes
his head yeah he's like I got away with
this one I got away with it you know I
mean let me sip out the chest bra mug
here hmm yeah that was losing yeah oh
yeah
look at oh I feel so badly for a Wonder
Liang right now